Two more seasons we're gonna get to do
all that stuff we talked about we're
gonna be building mark's character we're
gonna be doing all we're gonna be going
to space there might be some extra
leaving if i could spoil something
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
invincible season 2 video robert kirkman dropped
a teaser a while ago and obviously we have all the
in-credit scenes just teasing all the big stories
they have coming in the next couple of seasons
some of the stories that they set up and that
robert kirkman was talking about recently will
spill into season 3 probably even beyond that as
well so if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i will be doing
invincible season 2 videos robert kirkman did say
they'd already started work on that but he didn't
confirm exactly when it was going to be released
it actually takes way longer to finish animation
than it does for live action stuff and on top of
that one of the cool things about the invincible
series even though it's animated they actually do
it is an hour long series although it's hour long
with commercials if it were to air on broadcast
so really it's more like 45 minutes per episode
but that's double the length of a normal animated
episode so it just takes them a really long time
to actually get those episodes out if you didn't
see the video robert kirkman also posted a video
where he was talking to steven yoon who plays
invincible mark grayson about them being renewed
for season 2 and season 3 one of the reasons why
they renewed them for season 2 and season three
at the same time is just because it takes a long
time to do each season and they want them to be
able to work ahead so this is a huge break between
season 2 and season three you have just heard from
amazon that we have been picked up for uh season
2 yeah also getting picked up for season three
as well season 2 and three but just to start with
the biggest teaser that he talks about is angstrom
levy he's going to be the main villain of season
2 but obviously there'll be many other villains
that show up during the different episodes
the really cool thing about his character is
that he's a multiverse villain so the way robert
kirkman talks about the future of the show is that
they'll continue to escalate with each season so
just in terms of world building they'll be getting
into multiverse territory with alternate versions
of invincible other universes where things went
down very differently they'll also be getting into
the coalition of planets more as alan the alien
teased in their big war against the voltromites
and what's going on in other parts of the universe
they use the flaxsense during season one to tease
a little bit of the multiverse because they came
from an alternate dimension where time moves a
little bit differently but angstrom levy is like
the fullest expression of the multiverse concept
the comic book timeline for his story is just a
little bit different because it overlaps with the
mahler twins and some of the things that they did
during season one so they might change it just
a little bit but robert kirkman did confirm that
they would continue to change the comic book
story for the tv episodes they did the same
thing during season one if you read the comic book
you noticed that there was a bunch of story lines
that they just got rid of that they just skipped
over in a bunch of stuff from later in the comics
that they moved up like when robot basically
cloned himself another body using the maulers
that doesn't really happen in the comics till
around when they're doing the angstrom levy stuff
because angstrom levy also winds up breaking
the maulers out of prison but they just did
that during season one so either they'll change
that during season 2 or they'll just play it for
more comedy because invincible even though it's
very wtf plays a lot of these moments for comedy
like the maulers get broken out of prison and
they wind up breaking that same guard's arm again
but without getting too deep into his storyline
basically he breaks the maulers out of prison to
help him create another mind transference device
that they normally just use for cloning themselves
only angstrom levy doesn't want to clone
himself he wants to accumulate the sum total
of all knowledge from as many alternate realities
as possible so even without the mauler's help he's
able to construct a device that allows him to
travel to alternate realities he uses that to
assemble a team of other versions of himself
from alternate realities then modifies the
mahler's device that it'll allow him to transfer
or basically download all the knowledge from all
of his copies into his own mind making him this
all-knowing villain but as he activates the device
cecil learns about what he's doing and calls
markin to stop him in the maulers and even though
they play it for a little bit of comedy like mark
is still learning to be a superhero so he kind
of fumbles his way through the fight but he's so
powerful that they're not really a threat to him
so they just play it for some funny moments and
he inadvertently breaks angstrom levy's machine
while it's in the middle of downloading all the
knowledge from his multiverse duplicates and even
though it kind of works it does download a lot
of their knowledge into his mind it also winds
up leaving him horribly disfigured and he swears
revenge on invincible and uses the multiverse to
pursue that he's a really cool character but as
you can see they play the character for a lot
of comedy but the other cool thing about his
character is that through him they get to do
all these other different versions of invincible
because it's the multiverse like during his first
appearance he's grabbing another angstrom levy
from a version of earth where invincible actually
went to the dark side and agreed to help his
father omniman take over the planet he's grabbing
this alternate angstrom levy right in the middle
of this same fight scene that he had with his
father in the finale of the tv show only on this
version of earth invincible instead of saying no
to him actually said yay viltromites and they
start to take over the planet so eventually they
wind up doing a bunch of really cool looking evil
iterations of invincible from different universes
through angstrom's run as a villain in the comics
culminating in what they call the invincible war
is sort of like their version of a reverse marvel
secret wars type of event where instead of a bunch
of alternate reality heroes teaming up with each
other it's angstrom levy unleashing a team of evil
versions of invincible on the main universe one
of the other big things that robert kirkman was
hyping up during season 2 was the coalition of
planets now alan the alien explained a little bit
to mark what was going on with that and what their
main goal is trying to build support in the rest
of the universe to rebel against the viltrumite's
and get rid of them like the rest of the universe
versus the veltromites you learn a little bit more
about the day-to-day with the coalition of planets
and alan the aliens backstory he explained a
little bit of his backstory during season one
but i think we'll just get more of him during
season 2 i'm assuming that seth rogen will come
back to do the voice for his character that whole
arc in the comics is called the viltromite war
that's sort of like their big avengers infinity
war type of moment where they actually do fight
the viltrumites they do have a plan but it doesn't
go down exactly the way you think it would we'll
also probably meet some of the other voltromites
during season 2 there are many that you see during
the comics but after omniman conquest is one
of the next big ones that mark winds up going
against and then eventually you work your way up
to thragg who's sort of the de facto leader of the
viltromite people there's also a lot of viltromite
history that they only brushed over really quickly
during season one they'll probably get deeper
into that during season 2 and season 3 there
are a lot of other minor villains that you see
during those end credit scenes like you see the
maulers get rearrested locked back up like i said
they're a big part of the angstrom levy plot so
either they'll break them back out again and use
it for some comedy or they'll find some other way
for angstrom levy to get their technology you see
the flaxsense preparing to attack earth again and
declaring revenge on omniman because he basically
wiped out their entire planet that was probably
one of the coolest moments too watching him go ham
on an entire planet in the span of what seems like
just a couple weeks just long enough for him to
grow some facial hair there we see the titan has
taken over as the new boss of the city after they
got rid of his old boss it just seems like he's
going to continue to be a thing but it's sort of
like the devil you know doc seismic is back and
they've escalated his threat he's controlling
a whole bunch of magma golems this time
probably one of the bigger teasers though is cecil
inspecting the new upgraded reaniman because they
actually did give omniman a run for his money
they overwhelmed him for a little bit before
he took them down but these are still very early
versions of these that they continue to iterate on
it's sort of like terminators like they get better
and better over time and even though they portray
the viltromites like they're totally unkillable
except other voltromites like a viltromai could
kill another viltromite in battle beast could
probably kill a voltronite like he almost kills
mark for the most part the way they portray them
during season one they're relatively unkillable
that was cecil's whole thing like they were
trying to find ways to kill viltromite cells and
they couldn't do it like whatever we do we can't
find a way they just won't die eventually they do
find voltromite weaknesses that they can't exploit
also through the coalition of planet storyline as
well but some of that stuff like the voltromite
war storyline they might not get into till many
seasons later like season 3 season 4. some of
that stuff is way further ahead in the comics
for the most part it just seems like angstrom
levy will be the main storyline for season 2 maybe
that'll culminate in the season 2 finale with them
doing a version of the invincible war storyline
even though it sounds really epic a bunch of
alternate reality versions of invincible fighting
the main version of invincible it only lasted for
a single issue so it was actually pretty short war
and even though omniman took off at the end of
the episode like he finally decided that he did
care about mark and he wasn't going to kill him
so he had to find some way to make up for because
his current marching orders from thragg from the
viltrumite command structure were to take over
other planets and he had chosen to take over earth
that had been his mission for the last 20 years in
order to make up for that failure for not taking
over earth he has to go find another planet to
take over and that leads to another big storyline
in the reveal of another big character so without
getting too deep into that i don't know if they're
going to wind up doing the oliver character during
season 2 if that'll be a big reveal or wtf moment
and maybe like the finale or if they'll save that
for season three like i said during season one
there was a lot of storyline that they pulled
from way further ahead in the comics and moved it
up so they might do the same thing with season 2
just do storyline from way further ahead in the
comics but if you have not read the comics it
actually ended in 2019 so you can actually read
the entire comic book story now they won't wind
up doing everything from the comics and they will
change a bunch of stuff but it is still a really
cool story and it'll give you a pretty good idea
for some of the stuff that they'll do in future
seasons but the big takeaway is that with each
season they will continue to escalate the conflict
things will get bigger more galactic crazier and
crazier obviously season 2 is just pushing that
into multiverse storytelling there's also a lot
of other stuff during season 2 that they'll cover
that i talked about during my finale video from
season one so i'll link that at the end of this
too i'm not really expecting to see a bunch
of footage from season 2 till either the very
end of this year maybe sometime early next year
but i do think that they'll probably be able to
get season 2 out by late next year at the latest
but while you wait for everything click here for
my invincible season 1 finale video and click
here for my brand new thor 4 love and thunder
first look video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!